ah
[Music]
the entire premise of our Republic rests
on an informed citizenry Americans need
to understand what their government is
doing at all the different levels only
journalists provide that service in the
interest of the truth you can't have
freedom without knowledge and education
of what's going on and that's the
journalists job is very very big
ambitious core curriculum and that means
that everyone here gets fundamentally
educated they study the great subjects
the highest subjects about pious things
that gives them tools first of all to
know what good writing is but second to
know how things that are going on - they
fit in the story of the world so we have
kids from every discipline here who are
very equipped to become journalists
I think Hillsdale provides you with a
really cohesive curriculum and as a
journalist that helped me become a
critical thinker it helped me come up
with what good questions are the liberal
arts gives you a wide breadth of
knowledge and you've got to get to see
the world in lots of different ways for
different philosophies and studies and
that's really important in journalism to
be able to look at one story through
every different angle to understand the
motivation to put yourself in other
people's shoes John Miller head of the
DAO journalism program at Hillsdale is
himself an outstanding journalist and
still committing great journalism
everyday every week at national review
he understands what makes a story
compelling true and important at the
heart of the program is our campus
newspaper the collegian comes out weekly
during the semesters
you'll learn journalism by doing
journalism by going and writing the
stories doing the interviews laying them
out on a newspaper page and then seeing
it come out at the end of the week and
watching students read it and get the
reaction I love spending Wednesday
nights in the collegian office the
editor in chief and the news editor and
I we would work together on stuff and we
argue and to be dramatic and I have
really fond memories of this now because
it's a great teaching it
so basically what's putting out a
newspaper is like which is what I do
every day now in all the ways it's
really representative of what it takes
to be successful in a really meaningful
career once you graduate college the
long nights for studying the rigorous
demands that I thought almost Ron fares
at times and really helped prepare me
for what it took to be a journalist here
where you have deadlines you have
multiple stories a day you're
increasingly more competitive journalism
environment or more and more as demanded
[Music]
well I think one of the coolest things
about the DAO journalism program the
opportunity for networking with really
incredible journalists I mean while I
was there we had Naomi Shafer Riley come
in she spoke with our class talking with
her I was able to actually pitch her an
idea as a student that ended up
published in The Wall Street Journal
while I was still in Hillsdale it was
just this amazing opportunity for me to
be faced with this group of extremely
eager 18 19 and 20 year olds how eager
they were to do the work to ask the
questions that are necessary not only to
be a good journalist but to be a good
citizen to be a professional we're kind
of a career development office for
people interested in the media we work
very hard to help our students land jobs
upon graduation in fact everybody who
miners in journalism who wants a job in
journalism pretty much gets one I would
much rather hire somebody who knows
something and teach them the craft then
find someone who's only learned the
craft but doesn't know any the
journalism is a minor there right so you
get to sort of dip your toes in it he
learned some important things but at the
same time the emphasis remains on solid
scholarship and solid citizenship if you
learn the important stuff that much
easier to learn the journalism stuff
the framers understood the journalists
occupy a special role in our republic
that's why the framers in the Bill of
Rights has the very first amendment to
the Constitution protected a free press
and the freedom of speech at Hillsdale
as part of the Dow journalism program
they teach the Constitution they want
young honest reporters to understand a
special place that they occupy an
American society they do a great job